Oop! [Muffin falls] [Bouncing noise]
Five-second rule!
I just cleaned the floor, it's probably fine, right?
A lot of people swear by the five-second rule,
that if you drop a piece of food and pick it up before
five seconds, it hasn't been on the floor long enough
to pick up dangerous bacteria.
Is that really true?
To find out,  we're going to need to do an experiment.
It's time to Science!
[Snazzy background music]
To figure out if the five-second rule is
true,
we need to test whether food dropped on the floor
for a long time picks up more bacteria than food
dropped on the floor for a short time.
We'll start with a hypothesis.
Food picked up after five seconds will collect
fewer bacteria than food picked up
after 50 seconds.
But we have a little problem.
Microbes are much, much too small to see
with the naked eye.
This makes measuring them a bit tricky.
What we're going to have to do is grow the microbes
into colonies large enough to see.
To do this we need some sort of incubator
that can maintain a nice, warm temperature
of 37 degrees Celsius
that bacteria would happily grow in.
Think you need a lab to do this? Nope.
Building a DIY incubator is simple.
I built one based on the home incubators
people use to hatch chicken eggs.
Take a standard foam drink cooler
and cut a small hole on the side.
Then plug a 25-watt incandescent lightbulb
into the hole as a heat source.
To see inside, put a piece of glass
or a picture frame into the top.
Next, poke a very small hole near the bottom
and stick a remote digital thermometer inside
to keep tabs on the temperature.
Finally, plug in the lightbulb.
The foam from the cooler traps heat in
and lets the incubator get nice and toasty.
Over the next day, cut a few extra holes on the sides,
as needed, to release some of the heat
and keep the temperature inside
exactly where you want it.
Okay, we've got an incubator.
Now we need an experiment.
I want to drop something fun so I chose...
bologna. [whipcrack sound effect]
We're gonna use a gel-like substance called agar
to grow our microbes. It's made of algae
and full of things that bacteria like to eat.
In this experiment I want to compare bologna
that's been dropped for five seconds
to bologna that's been dropped for 50 seconds.
So I just need two groups,  right?
Wrong!
After all, we don't know how clean our floor is.
And we don't know if our food
will grow bacteria on its own.
In the end, I need to culture six groups.
I need one where nothing happened. That's my control.
I need another with bologna that was never dropped,
to find out if it grows bacteria on its own.
Then, I don't know how clean the average floor is
which means I need to compare both
clean and dirty floors.
I got one section of floor as clean as I
possibly could get it.
I used ethanol to kill anything on the surface.
The other, I had a little fun with.
I'll drop bologna on clean and dirty sections of floor
for five and 50 seconds each.
Once the agar is firm it's time to start dropping food.
Keep in mind we want to keep everything
around the experiment as clean as possible to prevent
foreign bacteria from interfering with our results.
Wearing gloves and a lab coat can help.
I'm also doing my experiment
around a lot of lit candles.
It's not because I love romance. It's because
the candles draw the air upward, which means
fewer bacteria from the air will settle on my dishes.
I can't just do one plate per drop.
I did a preliminary test to find out how many plates
I need to run to get accurate data.
I found out I'll need to run six plates per group
to get a large enough sample.
Alright, [whip crack noise] ... it's bologna time.
[snazzy background music] [Science!]
Now, we put our plates in the incubator
and wait.
Every 24 hours for the next three days
I take out my plates and photograph them.
Then we can use the free software Image J
to figure out how many microbes grew into colonies.
My results show first that bacteria can grow anywhere.
Even my clean control wasn't very clean.
But they also show that five seconds just
doesn't seem to matter.
If you drop your bologna on the floor
you're going to suffer the bacterial consequences.
Longer times might mean more bugs...
But life... finds a way - onto your food.
I'm not the only person to debunk the five-second rule.
Several studies have tested it.
Heck, the Mythbusters even did it.
And they all show that once food hits floor
microbes jump on board.
Now keep in mind, just because there's microbes
on your food, doesn't mean you're going to get sick.
Our guts are pretty good at fending off microbial invaders.
But it's probably good to play it safe.
So if you drop food on the floor maybe it's best
just to let it lie. [gasp] Yeah. Especially that.
Need more details to do this yourself?
Check out the links in the description.
Got ideas for me to try? Put them in the comments.
Thanks very much to Iain Sawyer
and Claire Adrian-Tucci for their help with this project.
Don't forget to subscribe for more awesome experimental goodness.
[jazzy background music]